hello welcome to this video
round nine of tata steel
2013 played in vikanze holland or the
netherlands
to be
more correct
all right so let's see um what um
pairings we got today
seven games as usual and i'll start with
our daily um berlin wall
kayaking against hari krishna
yeah it's um unfortunately again this
this line
which is rather unattractive
to watch i must admit
white now goes for castles knight e4 d4
96 and we got the famous end game that
basically won crom nick the world
championship in 2000 against kasparov
and um
since then this opening has become
one of the main battlegrounds of one e4
actually
and the main problem for white to get
anything going
yeah this end game again tried
i'm not an expert at all i can only tell
you some general things h3 is a useful
move in general in those structures as
white
often uses g4 later with four against
three in the kingsidis where he's
usually trying to get something
black played bishop d7 and this idea is
mostly
because black tries to secure his king
on the queen side we can
add this move pair
and what black is often trying to do is
get the king to b7
and maybe c5 bishop c6 at a later stage
in this game however white plays
something different
he plays an immediate g4
knight e7 knight g5 and
this thread actually
gets black to play king e8 nevertheless
so b6 um doesn't look so useful anymore
but
probably you needed to do you need to
you needed to do it
um
bishop e8 um is the other way to defend
the pawn
but um it looks um somewhat somewhat
passive
one problem could be
something like this
and i'm not quite sure what uh what
black is is doing here
you probably don't want to take and f6
it's debatable how you would probably
get this pawn
i don't know it's uh it's not entirely
clear but king e8 is the
move that had been played before
and now white um plays f4
gaining space
f6 immediately
getting rid of this imposing knight
we now get this kind of position where
white very quickly has pushed his
kingside pawns but he must be careful on
the other hand
his own king is um quite exposed and if
uh like man just to coordinate pieces
then the two bishops can be really
problematic for white
yeah h5
immediately attacking g4 and white
played the g4 g5 himself he doesn't
don't want to um doesn't want to allow
the h5 to to be opened
so g5 is um attacking f6 also with the
knight
and black decided
oops
oops i did it again
like decided to um
to take the f5 pawn
and white and return god f6
so we as mentioned god got in real
opening of the king side here
so on both kings look a bit exposed
just look at those kind of ideas
it was only a checkup like needed to
take care about
the d7 bishop also
knight 92 bishop g7 yeah bishop c5 also
was possible
but he wanted to attack this immediately
i would say
rook f8 getting
the rook into play
and tm black actually
sacrificed the h5 pawn he never could um
could cover with g6s
then knight f5 would be a knight f4
would be a problem
so this is why we gave this but it
wasn't really um
a big problem black gets this move
and
now
puts this knight on e2 in a
very annoying pin
white exchanges before this bishop can
get even more
dangerous
and now covers the knight rookie one
looks very bad in account of rook 828
and white loses a piece
so rookie one was necessary
oops
rook f2 was necessary sorry
rookie one didn't work rook f2 was
necessary and now rookie 8 attacking the
knight needed to move away
rookie one and here
yeah black looks very very active and um
it's clear that uh it's white that um
whiter needs to be cautious yeah
but it seems to be um beholding
black doesn't have any big um
improvement here to attack the king the
king looks really weak
but you don't really manage to get on
the long diagonal to
to make something happen there's also
this b3 bishop b2 idea
so um
black played bishop to d5
threatening rook h1 checkmate so white
needed to take
and now played b3 planning bishop b2
even winning the rook with check so
likely to step out of the check
um and here white simply has no choice
he needs to
um return with bishop b2 one pawn
like got this back but if you wouldn't
do that um you will never ever move any
of those pieces
and black guy gets more activity going
so it was certainly necessary to do that
black got one pawn back here on g5
and now we have an endgame with the
equal material
which pretty much instantly
fizzles out to nothing
you can try a bit maybe as black as
you've got
more activity the h pawn is not really
a dangerous pass ball it's more like a
weakness but all in all it should be a
draw really
and
a couple of moves later
a draw was agreed
um
maybe you could could analyze this end
game a bit if you have
like a three hour video but it's it's
it's actually not completely clear cut
but
it's um
it's it's george at the end and they
made the draw
okay so
let's see what game i'm going to do next
i have a list now to make sure that i
don't forget one
so uh
okay wang hao against uh caruana
and um
got the slav again caruana also playing
the sloth
and with e3 we've got this slow
slow sloth as it is entitled
in um
amongst others boris avrock's book
yes slow sloth is quite fitting white um
doesn't go for the most aggressive move
knight c3 which
is simply putting more pressure on the
center but also
allows the dtx deform which
is as solid as ever for black i think
so this is why white goes e3 often to
avoid this um
this line e3 also has got some points
against the e6
it's not so clear that e6 is really um
a great move here
black can play that but white has got
additional options like v3 now to avoid
um typical marin
like in the game aronian arnon this
brilliancy that the world champion
played in round four
white would be able to avoid that
okay this line at least
avoid disaster you can with the various
various setups but it's interesting
alternative but e3
is very often answered by bishop f5 or
bishop g4 and also here caruana just
develops the bishop and afterwards wants
to play e6
which is obviously very solid white has
got his bishop locked in so
this is um
for black saying okay i will even
be better than you in a way i will
develop first and then play e6
okay h3
retreats
and now white took on d5
yeah
very often black doesn't retreat but
takes on f3 it's actually
not so um often played to keep the
bishop but what white is trying to do is
to
very often with this move
to put some pressure on b7 and play on
the queen side as this bishop is
far away from
this part of the board
but in fact um
about how didn't really uh
okay took on f3 now this is this is why
so uh black actually um lost the tempo
he could have taken on
f3 instantly but it's a difference now
white has exchanged if um
black would have taken here
let's say something like this
white probably wouldn't exchange on d5
here he waited for the exchange
and then took on f3
well queen f3
e6
and we see that without the light squad
bishop black has a super solid position
you can put the pawns on light squares
the bishop is dark squared so
it all
works very nicely together
and this is all
very simple and needs no big explanation
a3 prepares rook c2 it would
would have
been answered here with knight and b
form so
a3 covering this uh the square
and
white now
doubles on the c file but
the c file while
being the open file um is still
relatively um
yeah closed due to due to the knights
that simply um
block this file
and
yeah black is super solid in this
position
he played rook d8 which is interesting
he has just played rook to c8
two moves ago but this seems to over
protect d5 and he was probably uh now
switching to a plan with uh e6 e5
and we see that black manages to play
the central advance
and
yeah now white played 92 which is a very
interesting
tactical move
the problem here also was uh what do you
do about this e5 move if white would
take
and black would play a queen takes e5
and
this is um
crude but very effective threat
which um white probably needs to answer
with a move like g3
which is really ugly
white can
of course repair this a bit with stuff
like bishop f1 g2 and so on but it takes
a long time
and black is perfectly centralized you
also
after opening the center ask yourself
what what are these rooks doing on the c
file not much and this bishop is also
not great white needs lots of time
to get them a good coordination bishop
to g2 knight e2 bishop to c3 and so on
this takes a long time black is fine
here
so this is why it didn't take he played
knight e2 and this is very tactical now
after e4 you see that this bishop has no
e4 is very provocative he took on a7
and this um
a6 of course and this is
initiating now very long tactical
sequence
um yeah black obviously cannot take it
as rook takes c6
just leaves white with one extra pawn
and probably
two in the long run the a pawn is also
weak so this is easy
but black's idea was after bishop takes
a6 he just played knight to a7 this is
why i was
mentioning a7 earlier
this is a fun move now this bishop
doesn't have a square
and at first you think oh they just
blundered the piece but
it's not the case white has
a real really funny move to um to
continue all this
he played knight g3
the idea is knight to f5
taking on d6 and bishop b4 and we see
exactly this in the game
it's uh it's rather false black now
took on g3
probably this is the best move
alternatively he could have taken here
something like this
something like this
and this isn't isn't um completely clear
really
but i would say
i actually would um
prefer
white a little bit in this position
the rooks are nicely doubled on the on
the c farm
and
lots of end games are
are really preferable for white
especially if the queens get off
and you manage to put pressure on the a6
pawn if you win the spawn you also win
the game the knights are often very
helpless against rooks and um
and pass pawns or potential pass pawns
on the queen side
but
it's not super clear
in the game we got something uh
similar motifs but it's a different
position he took on g3
now a6 and rook c7 bishop b4 was also
possible leading to similar positions as
before but this was the intention rook
c7
rook d7 only move a7 was hanging
and now bishop b4 yeah and um
here black um also could play queen e6
also was a similar position as before
but only with more activity and the rook
exchange
which probably favors white
he took rook takes c7 and gave the queen
and now we have a really
unusual
material um
balance here
black's got two knights and the rook
against queen and pawn
which is really a rare very rare
material
situation
she had a quick rookie exchange
and white invading here so while it's
activity
um at first sight looks uh sufficient to
probably um
make a draw
it's hard to believe that white would
would
win this
actually got even the a6 pawn but black
in return
managed to get some peace
coordination
and it's
not at all easy look at this
now
those pieces work really nicely together
and it's uh difficult to
further advance the pawns
in fact we see
after a couple of more moves
which don't really change the position
much
that white now played the move from
a5
this is probably a mistake but it's very
difficult to
to play this position um queen a7
probably just uh
keeps the position balanced
with the possible continuation of rook
b7
queen beck and rook back so just
playing this
kind of repetition
um the problem is that what white did a5
could um oops i'm sorry i confused
here for a5 i had this repetition in a5
on 35
the problem is that uh now black
probably could
get an advantage even he played knight
a4
and
better would have been to
go back to c8
and this is really a bit of a problem
now
for white
he actually doesn't have anything else
than b6 almost zuk's one the queen
cannot really move b5 is hanging you
must advance in order to not lose the
pawn
and now black has a strong move knight
e7 and the idea is to
play it's it's a long sequence but it's
hard to prevent
knight to c6 knight to c4 and then grab
a5
and white um doesn't have much
to prevent that really
i at least don't don't see him don't see
anything
white uh stays just to put put the
threat on the board
and a5 is gone and if if five is gone
then the game is gone
like wins those two pawns it's pretty
much over
so this was a chance but um
typical computer line but certainly it's
possible to find this but
three minutes left is not easy at all
so knight a4
the difference is just that this knight
isn't coordinating so well
right now played b6
and
check
this was what
karwana had in mind which is also
looking uh looking nice i mean look at
this queen the queen is basically
trapped
black's pieces all protect each other
it's very nice those knights protect
each other and the rook um takes away
squares
white simply has no constructive move he
can just can just stay
but
the problem with knight f4 was
that the other move was probably leading
to clear advantage
and this is
just um just the draw
but there are some things still
happening in the game
we have a couple
of moves which don't really change the
position much
and now white went g3
which
also
allows black
for some activity now and probably for
an advantage
black played the relatively
passive or let's say move that does
nothing
rook b8 he could could have gone rook c3
here
it's not an easy decision of course
because white
would be allowed now to to move the
queen again
so uh the logical move to consider is
this
and then black can play
in this fashion
and the amazing thing is that
look at those pieces they are so well
coordinated now the knights protect each
other the knight on d6 protects e4 and
f7 so it's all protected and also the
knights prevent all kinds of checks
queen b5 check queen b7 check
and
the problem is those pawns now will just
fall
a5 and b6 will both
go away in the next couple of moves and
this
leads to white's defeat
rook c3 would have probably won the game
i don't see anything at least and
computer also
but it's um a hard move to to decide to
play him of course he had time but
didn't didn't find it
okay
rook b8 king b3 and now
we have
some more moves going on but
really not happening too much the whites
white screen was trapped so
and blackhead could not really move the
the rook away from the backrank and then
the queen 8 was possible there was just
this golden opportunity of rook c3 but
this seems to be
gone now
yeah white um played it now actively
with b7 and
initiating this idea
so we see that check
check
quite some some funny
some funny
things that still happen to him check
what what's idea now is to promote the
pawn
of course the knight is a very stupid
defender
and black can
just barely
stop the pawn
but
this makes sure that black's king has no
active idea
check
and
we have this
funny draw now
white uh
stalemate
takes and we have got to stand mate
so quite quite a funny funny way to end
the game white also could have just sit
and wait probably and uh
nothing much would have happened but she
calculated this correctly to draw
quite a quick quite funny way to to draw
yeah enters chances for both sides
actually
to um to
get something mostly for black though
um
all right the next game is let's see
what my list is doing eliko against
ireland
do this somewhat more quickly i said it
wasn't so um
exciting and admittedly
we had an exciting looking opening the
night off
we should be three by lego has standard
move and anand went knight to g4 which
is
um a sharp
way to play for black and to get
somewhat
original positions um white played
bishop c1 though
this is um sort of declining
the invitation to uh to play bishop g5
which would
be answered by
this um
this setup
very sharp
you know favored also of kasparov's when
he was still playing
um but bishop c1 is the kind of move
which
asks black okay you've got this extra
move are you sure that your knight is
good on g4
and black's best move is actually to
just retreat and we got
the original knight of position again
okay of course it's not the draw
immediately
as lekko played f3 now which prepares
bishop e3 without allowing knight g4 but
this takes away some options for white s
you don't always want the pawn on f3
so we have a couple of very standard
moves
white's plays on the king side h4 g5
black has this typical ideas
of counterplay on the queen side on the
c file
and using the c4 square for example
v5 and now rook g1
yeah i'm not um familiar with the
exact theoretical implications here
rook g1 is certainly a useful move and
lots of positions
preparing g5 and then knight a5 this is
an interesting idea the main point is
that white at some point
maybe plays knight to d5 and
establishing
a pawn on d5 so that the knight can be
secured on c6
of course the direct idea is a knight to
c6 winning
oops knight to
c6
and taking only seven winning the d6
pawn so if black would play a nothing
move then
uh would i would even win the the piece
here
okay so this is why black covered the c6
square
g5 pushing the knight away and now
king b1
for the preparation move knight d5 is
what
whites want to wants to play in the long
run but he wants to keep a2 amongst
others safe
knight f4 yeah an interesting way to
play
instantly um
getting this uh offside knight into the
game again
um white um now took uh he didn't to
take it sorry we played a3 but if white
would take just to have a look at this
if white would take twice
need to check this then black has the
very strong move knight a4
and um
this actually loses instantly this
knight is hanging
so you cannot you cannot really retreat
as then
this move actually kills immediately
and if white would take here
then queen a5
knight back
and rook c3 also
completely destroys white's position
a2 is the issue
it's um
completely winning
so cannot grab on f4 he played a3 first
controlling this important square queen
c7 and now it took
yeah now we see the mentioned idea of
knight a5
to use it on c6
which is of course an attractive square
to um
to to aim for
i like now played queen c5
an important alternative here was
but i guess one that he pretty quickly
discarded
is to to take here
at first it looks uh quite good you take
this pawn and attack the knight
queen d5 queen a5
bishop three
here black has um
won a pawn it's seven against six
but um it's a position that
i don't think that black really wants to
play
white is much easier to play in this
position as
he's got this excellent bishop on d3
which is
nicely anchored
it protects both the king and
attacks on this diagonal and white has
an easy way to
improve his position he can also try to
win the f pawn and it's also not easy to
um to defend
so white is certainly better in this
position
so this is why he played queen c5 this
attacks the rook
this is why it went to g4
rookie 8
and yeah white cannot take f4
he secures g5 to threaten it but he
couldn't take here because of
bishop takes
and of course queen takes
was completely out of the question as
c2 is hanging
this was um
the reason for h4 this threatens to take
and now
bishop f8
activating the rook hook takes and now
rook takes d5 an important
move and in fact
after
the reply by white bishop d3a draw was
agreed we should quickly look at queen
takes d5 this is important
black can take
to play this to get
the pawn back
and this leads to
a pretty george position
in the game while knight b3 was played
with the draw offer which was
accepted a possible line is um something
like this queen e3
rookie four
luke takes takes
something like this with with a very
level position
we've got this opposite colored bishops
that in the long run can easily um
make it even more drawish so um very
unexciting position that was agreed to
drawn
okay next move next game
who you find against um carlsen
so we've got uh
who you found being the real underdog in
this tournament against the huge
tournament favorite cards and also
played an excellent tournament
tournament
as we are
actually
but now i used to used to see he's
playing
brilliantly all the time
and
it's hard to believe but
who you fun played the ponciani opening
an opening that i really
ridiculed quite a lot in the past
um also with my video my opening
repertoire video where i recommended d5
the funny thing is that carlson himself
played the ponciani earlier in the
tournament against hari krishna and
hai krishna played knight f6
d4 d5 which is really not the best way
to combat this opening
and
carlton
also didn't play d5 which is
the theoretical um way to
to tackle this which is also what i
recommended in my video but he simply
doesn't play it
and he also didn't seem to fear it a lot
as
white
okay you went knight f6
d4 and now um he played differently to
hari krishna
the main move actually is knight takes
e4 but this is very difficult to win
as this kind of
oops
this kind of position here
which can be forced by white this kind
of position here is uh very very
difficult for black to
play for win it's um very solid but
white has slight space advantage and is
arguably even a little bit more
comfortable
it's not a
big issue
but black has no real idea to play for a
win
this is why he played etax d4 which is
not played often but is surprisingly
good actually
um the idea is that after e5 which is
certainly the
the most interesting move black plays
knight d5 in fact even knight e4 is a
move
the idea being on queen e2
to play f5 e takes f d5
this is um very interesting for black
and
probably um something worth
investigating
this has some theoretical importance
also
not uh so much because of the ponciani
or maybe it comes into fashion again i
don't believe it really but maybe it's
possible but looking at this position
after d4 takes
this actually could also arise from
another opening and this is
this kind of gambit here
here black has a good antidote in d5 but
this is a bit dull
black can also play here and then we
have a transposition to the game
it can be a good alternative if you
don't want to play this
d5 move against
this gambit
okay back to the game
95 bishop c4 attacking the knight
as mentioned knight e4 is also possible
but knight d5 is the most solid option
knight b6 queen b3 d5
yeah and um
this looks uh very healthy for black
he managed to play the e5 and d5
therefore
he's got no problems in developing his
pieces
and um
if you look at this
this already um
applies some pressure on the center
um
yeah maybe i'm a bit biased here because
i play e4 e5 as black guy i already
would prefer black here just from my
experience in those positions
black has some play against d4 as
mentioned he can play f6
attacking this pawn chain and i'm not so
sure what really white's ideas
in this position but um
it's it's probably um about equal but i
think black
like is somewhat easier to play at least
i would uh know
for black what to do for white i'm not
so sure what to recommend
okay we've got a couple of um
logical move f6 attacking the pawn chain
and she um
ignored this for the moment
cards now played queen d7 preparing um
long castling
f takes e5 was also something to
consider
but
if black would try to
grab the pawn
then rookie one would be
really really dangerous
i think um
this is not playable probably
queen d7 is a good and a healthy move
and it also attempts right
to do something
directly now she first played h3 which
certainly a
useful move
bishop to h5
and now white has a tactical opportunity
and she um
was tempted to play this this is e6
and
it looks good
because this idea is quite nice
but
i think this probably already leads to
trouble for white
the problem is if if black would take
then knight g5 is the idea attacking the
the queen of course your own queen is
also hanging but if black would
take
knight e6 would leave this hang and
there's knight c7 also threatening so
this should be better for white
but um
oops queen e6
knight g5 you must consider to take
and then this would happen
and while not being completely clear
it's certainly to white's advantage to
gain the bishop pair here
like has a quite healthy structure still
but certainly this is better for white
than it was before
but um
accounts just played queen d6 and
ignored this pawn
and the issue is this pawn has zeros of
support
from the other units how
is this pawn going to survive
it's got knight c3 long castle
and now a4 trying to
play e5 and
get some attack going on the queen side
but he just stopped it
and by now you ask yourself what about
the spawn
in fact
it is lost now and now white
doesn't have any kind of
fancy tricks here if white would play
queen
and knight g5 now
there's even the
very cold shower queen takes e3 winning
a piece
there's still this one hanging
so
black is just the pawn up here
white um
tried a bit we've got some some activity
we've got rookie one with the temple
rook c1
but
it doesn't really
seem to be enough
bishop b4 gaining a tempo
and g5 another tempo for a useful move
and now knight c4 simply
obstructing the c file
and um yeah black is just a pawn up
it's as simple as that and there's no
big issue to to to defend here or
something
black has got activity all pieces into
play so no problems e6 was really
really wrong probably
yeah she took now
played queen to c2
yes this pin was very annoying and it
was
difficult to to break it
a move like g4 is pretty much suicide
weakening your king side even further in
fact if you look at this with the
computer g4 was an idea that i put into
it and it even gave
bishop takes foia as a possibility
and black has a very strong attack
something like this is even immediately
winning threatening g4
on h2 and on h1 there are there
mates are close to checkmates
so g4 was um really bad
okay queen c2
and now this bishop takes f3s
yes somewhat typical solution for
carlson he
calculated um the
coming moves precisely to a position
where he is just better and risk zero
um yeah he's got no losing risk and uh
and this i have a look takes
that what i want to say is he could have
played um
lots of other moves which were more
complicated but um
maybe maybe even better moves but moves
that would give white probably a little
bit more counter play
rook g8 bishop g6 are all interesting
let's say bishop g6 was interesting
queen takes takes
takes bishop f7 or forced
and now i move like um let's say h5 with
the idea g4
on
interesting and also bishop b3 it's
unfortunately covered
sorry
this year i thought bishop b3 was good
but it's not working
yeah black has a clear dominance in this
position he's got two two bishops this
is a weak pawn and you've got h4 g5 g4
coming also a great position
but there's more pieces on the board he
spotted this takes takes
knight takes this is forced
rook takes and this is simple
just protecting c4 and what is white
doing now
there's not much that white can do in
terms of
activity just one move and this he
certainly saw beforehand bishop
e5 yeah of course i'm using using the
pin here of this rook on f3
bishop d2
this was clear
check queen check
so
here he returned one pawn but at the end
the pieces that are left he's got great
rook
always putting pressure on those pawns
this is a somewhat loose bishop you
still have the extra pawn of course
and it's fairly simple to play
just protecting this pawn
and threatening g4
it's simply an extra pawn with no risk
at all
protecting the rook
and this is strong again you
he saw that the c pawn is hard to keep
so just c3
and bishop c5 and this is just a strong
position for the bishop
it puts pressure on the f pawn the a4
pawn is still very weak and black's got
this ideas of rookie 2
increasing pressure on the second rank
yeah all week
black's pieces coordinate nicely
yeah and this was um also
a very um deep calculation queen d2
didn't need to do that yet other moves
but this is very direct
threatening rook takes f2 winning
and in writing the the coming
sequence
and
the alternatives
weren't any better
should you go on g4 with check king
takes
queen takes on e2
and now this is all force queen c1 check
queen e1 only move quickly
queen e2 queen a4 so this was calculated
with queen d2
leading to um an endgame
with still the extra pawn
just one pawn not two but
the point is this a pawn
can be pushed
while his king is still safe
if white would push
one of her pawns then the king would be
wide open
so this is the difference here that's
not the the pure yeah body count one
more pawn let's uh that this pawn can
actually be used without weakening your
own king side
bishop e5 and now very good technical
play bishop d4 forcing the exchange um
if white would decline this like playing
this for example
then queen a1
check
yeah this is a
touchdown got a new queen coming
so white must must exchange no
other option and with queens on it's
it's fairly easy
yeah protecting
checks on the long diagonal and
threatening checkmate
check
and now just uh b5 tactical move
white took check always check queen
check
and takes
chat and now the b pawn is
is deciding
so all this this is all very similar
both
in both cams but the b pawn besides the
day
and it's just um
check
a couple of moments check
check
check
check
check
check yeah just um check
check
checks that white can give but
after this move she resigned
there's no way to
prevent
the the pawn from queening and
two or three moves
so um
the expected
i must say win by cards and against who
you found
he's simply in
brilliant shape and she's just not
playing
um
the kind of
super precise chess that
would prevent him from winning
this e6
move is in is interesting but
it seems to fall short in the long run
with the normal moves i don't know just
developing
it probably was would have been a harder
fight
okay so win for carlsen
next game is uh zukulov against venvili
and it really um
yeah it's really not much fun for me to
watch this uh play by zukulov i really
like his chess he's playing e4 e5 like i
do and i adopted many of his interesting
ideas but he's just
playing um terribly in this tournament
okay one of the
e3 lines that um zokolov is a big bit a
big expert on
yeah knight g2 is a so-called reshefsky
variation
i'm avoiding the double pawns
and very often we get this setup
here white has a number of
ideas to play
on
a new idea that
zukulov also suggested in his book about
this opening
is h3 the idea being a3
a5 preventing b4
and g4
what white is trying to do he's playing
for
a very long term
expansion on the on the king side
um the only job i guess it loses lots of
time and it's
somewhat weakening we see um if you look
at the next couple of moves when willie
is just playing
normal developing moves and
setting his position up
three
the ad the idea
is in fact to play
rook a2 and swing this over we see this
later
okay too
knight d8 and f5 i think was a really
good idea
to get
something going here
and um
dwight
even played this move
very long term white would like to play
e4 and
use his
space but
i don't really like this position it
looks very um
artificial
now the rook can swing over
but it it doesn't really look like
a harmonious position to me
in fact this game is very difficult to
to analyze as
it's
super complicated with this weird piece
positions
knight to h5 probably intending to
go to f4
yeah this was one idea with
b3a4 using this diagonal
black protected the knight and now white
snide
needed to drop back in this position at
first i thought that f4 would be very
good if you look at this white would
take with the pawn
then black could capture on f4
or capture here
i mean this kind of
position which looks very nice with the
knight on f4
and the very stupid bishop
but in fact after f4 white has the
interesting reply e4 with the idea to
play e5
and it gets really messy
hard to evaluate this position it's not
clear that white is better or something
but
it's really um
a big mess
so knight g5 is what he played
also pretty uh logical move
queen c1 yeah this was
saying
takes on f5
yeah probably going trying to go to f4
and now white has managed to
bring his knights
closer to black's king this whole
position is really very unclear
and
as mentioned um how to
to analyze really
bishop to e8
regrouping king h2
rook g8 and now then here's the critical
position
white um
could have played also some slow move
but zokulov decided to
really mix it up now he played the e4
i'm really not sure if this is a good
move or not but
it certainly changes the game a lot
um if black would take with the d pawn
on e4
then while its idea is revealed you can
play d5
which is very strong
in fact this is a very strange
p setup i black this
bishop v2 check
is so strong that it this year wins
instantly
white
just wins
if black would after d5 sorry um try to
defend by putting a knight to e5 i'll
put it on the board
also this one is
96 and
white is really winning
it takes
two takes
and this is the big point
check check
check
yeah and white is completely winning
using this rook even to attack this
lone king
so um
black i must be cautious about
the long diagonal
being open this is also why let's say
this is not working still this move
what he played was was fine he
just um
took off one of the knights
takes him
and here probably um black um made a
mistake but
i mean this position is so weird
that um it's
it's pretty easy to go wrong i probably
would have lost already because i would
be so confused about all these pieces
and on this
this clump of pieces here
okay um
he played knight to e6
and this um
leads to trouble
probably knight to f7 was better this is
the problem is here white can can open
it up now
and use the file it's not uh
black is not
in big trouble here but knight f7 was
probably better not to go into this pin
here black is um
like needs to be really cautious and in
fact
um
after queen to d7
queen three
here um
black needed to play rook a2 e8 this was
really the the move that keeps the
position together
he however played
knight g7 and
here
white could have could have won the game
and it's not really difficult so zokolov
really must be in terrible shape
um it was simply this move
and it is very fairly simple move
one of the first you would consider
really because it's it's a double attack
hangs and hangs
and
black really um
doesn't have
much
else than taking
and after queen takes
you can easily see that uh white is
winning
as um
or at least he's clearly better what
should this knight do there's also rook
e7 in this position
as a possibility this is why if you
would play
knight uh ahead here they're simply
rookie seven and black resigns
made on h7
can grab here but this is just a check
and
made next move or black needs to
give up the queen with the lost position
so this this was fairly easy let's say
this this and here
basically you can stop your calculation
as
it is clear that white is close to win
knight must retreat to the terrible
square g7
and then you have more than one good
option rook e7 rook e5
with this idea so white is what is
winning here
in fact he played um knight f4
which sports this
knight f7
covering a couple of critical squares
it was a very tempting move this knight
f5 black
would play a move like
let's say rookie 8 just for example have
a look at this position
stop the video and think about this what
is white's next move
okay i'm going to say it if black would
have played this
white has this neat
checkmate this new checkmate
so i think he was very much tempted by
this cute idea of course this is
something that
when really saw quickly it's easy to
spot but
this is a tempting move this is what i'm
getting at maybe this is why i didn't
really appreciate the queen form
okay knight f7
queen c3
um
and queen this reason mistake because it
allows
a tactic by black which fenway didn't
play
and this is also hard to understand
because it's also very simple
really
um he played rook c8
but the tactic was bishop g3
which is really fairly simple
needs to take
check knight h5 check and double check
so needs to go back
rook takes here and this is uh quite
easy now the rook is hanging
and the x and on g2 it's also an attack
so something like this maybe
and here
black can um
more than one idea but he's got the very
simple idea that just wins
takes
takes
rook takes f4 and resigns
rook g8 g3 or knight g5 over
this is um it's not really so difficult
to
to see that um black is clearly better
here
maybe he did some miscalculation
rook c8 rook c8 keeps a very good
position this
uh i must say that bishop g3 is just
winning
queen d2
bishop g5 and now
this is a terrible self pin
or not a self pin
but queen e2
sort of walked into this uh this pin
maybe um he should have tried something
else but there are no uh
no great squares maybe here
yeah bishop g5 still it's uh it's
terrible
yeah queen g2
and now
there's this knight h5 threat um
looming over white's head
he didn't find anything better than
h4 distracting this bishop
but it just really for one move
and still knight h5
it's absolutely no way to to now save
the game
this is what i call
a really really annoying pin right
gave the exchange
and
some moves later
exactly here
he resigned
so really disappointing game by
zukulov he's really completely out of
sorts in this
tournament
he um easily could have obtained a big
advantage on move 31
here playing after knight g7 playing
this queen f4 move instead in a couple
of movies bought this very complicated
position though so it's um
it's easy to um understand some of those
miscalculations
all right so
this um
game was won by van villi he was really
having a great tournament
must give him credit where credit is due
okay so next game is
la me against arunian
and i think it's it's also the
the last game am i right
i've got nakamura giri coming up this is
going to be epically long
all right this video okay let's go ahead
now me against aronia
okay symmetrical english
yeah fairly normal
position where black now plays g6
this early d6 bishop d7 is
quite interesting way to play
um this keeps a little bit more tension
in the position very often
um in the past um black has played
without d6 and bishop e7 just exchanging
on d4 and then playing d6
it
this keeps a little bit more tension as
mentioned
one idea this is quite funny is after e3
e3 really being a rather conservative
move must
say
white has alternatives with knight c2 or
others
um here aronian played the interesting
move h5
trying to use the fact that black hasn't
castled
and yeah h4 is um
not easy to prevent white can play h4
himself but
i'm not really sure that he wants to do
that
the problem with this move is that it
really makes the pawn structure very
unflexible
white um without h4 still has um
sometimes at least
ideas of playing at some point f3 e4
for example after this um this bishop is
exchanged
but this would really weaken the
structure now so h4 you don't really
want to play
he just played b3 h4
so developing
queen c8 this really looks like a blitz
game right black's trying to
mate quickly on the h-file
but
it's really a bit dangerous white cannot
completely ignore this
he decided to simplify
in this in this fashion
and it's understandable i mean la me is
a realistic person he thinks the draw is
not bad against aronian so
let's try to simplify the position a bit
yeah black cannot tolerate this knight
for long so he needs to take it
and in this position arguably
white um can be um
satisfied and maybe even retains a
slight advantage
the bishops are not
yet
a big factor but in the long run
it it can be good
the problem is why they are not
so brilliant is that this bishop is very
likely being traded off and then
this bishop this bishop on g2 is a bit
stupid looking at cd5 pawn
okay in fact there's not so much going
on king f8 rook c1 all very
normal looking moves
this is very very standard
looking
and now black um went ahead and
exchanged
the bishops the problem is that in
general that black
is in a bit of a traffic jam here on the
king's side if black would have casted
or
or the rook can
can be into
can be brought into play quickly then
black would have no problems at all but
here white is threatening rook c1 so
black needs to do something um to
get his pieces coordinated this is why
knight g4 was played
offering this exchange and white really
doesn't have much lc he changed now
and here
he decided to
grab a pawn
before check knight takes
queen a7
in fact instead of grabbing the pawn
white could also think about the rook
rooks the move a rook c-1
and maybe um this would have been an
interesting option here
the difference is
that now white really controls the sea
farm
he is still threatening this idea
and
it leads to interesting play black could
try for example
queen here threatening the mate on f2
then white has this check
and can play play something like e4
interesting a7 is still hanging and you
have the c farm this is not bad at all
in the game what i'm getting at white
wins this pawn
but black gets the c farm and gets the
active play
and it's difficult um i think to
suggest huge improvements afterwards
maybe white is
has got chances to coordinate better but
look at this what is happening
just a couple of moves
later black's got the activity now queen
is active rook is active
and um i don't really see how white
should make big progress he
actually managed it to get the queens
off
but even this isn't so great you cannot
easily advance the pawns e4 is uh
threatened now
by means of this g4 move
and black relatively quickly activates
the skin so
it
maybe it needs a much deeper analysis
but
i think that black has quite good
chances to
balance the position with this activity
a couple of moves later
you see that black has activated the
king
and
white cannot really make much progress
he decided to exchange him
attacking e4
and this
makes sure that e4 will stay weak
yeah just going for maximum activity
yeah it's um it's probably um
by far enough activity to to draw the
game
yeah f4 is actually a way to quickly get
rid of the rest of the pieces
it wasn't um
a fourth move white could have played
a passive way probably but
this just leads to
further simplifications
the idea being that
this g4 pawn can be um
one by by means of e5
um it's not a complete it's not a pawn
win it's a further exchange but
white will get to the spawn after king
b4
even e5 immediately was was possible and
played
knight takes rookie four
and dwight is the pawn down now
here but has no problem at all to to
draw the game
bishop back and g4 is now hanging
and there's also this move bishop to a2
and this um
secures the draw iron and played knight
to e3 you can also
look at this move
attacking f4
and then a possible draw is bishop a2
knight takes knight takes here king e4
king g4 king e5
king f3 and uh just that
the bishop is um easily
waiting for the pawn to get to sacrifice
itself
so
not much happening he just protected g4
but white has this counter play against
the the pawns
black has no way to make progress now
this should be 8 f7 is the idea
one idea and white can just stay
this is what he did
check
yeah now we have this idea
i actually pressed this
five move it once again
so white at the end decided to go there
and uh check in this way clarify all
this
check sacrificing a piece
but of course here
there are not any pawns left at all and
draw agreed
so um
maybe lamie had a chance to to play for
something if you wouldn't have grabbed
the pawn
after the pawn grab it was still
interesting but
maybe black was too active
hard to um how to say
i think aronian played maybe a little
bit too
provocatively to trying to
unbalance the position and maybe
got into some trouble
of course he wanted to win trying to
catch up but it's it's difficult
okay so now one game left and i'm not
going to forget it nakamura against giri
again forgetting nakamura's game would
have been embarrassing
um okay e4
and
this e6 move here
nakamura answered with b3 one of those
interesting offbeat lines
a6
signalizing um
that you might go for some hedgehog
c4 d6
yeah this is a very
hedgehog like d4
takes and now an interesting move white
could have played of course knight takes
d4 which looks very normal in the
sicilian but he played queen takes d4
this may be better
the idea is um
or at least that is more interesting i
would say
the idea is that
bishop a3
puts immediate pressure on the d6 pawn
and knight c6 the cellular move that you
want to play in this kind of structure
the knight usually belongs on d7
let's see what happens some normal
developing moves queen's c7 rook t1
rook t8 yeah anticipating the pressure
on the d pawn
and white played this bishop a3
and um
i think gui played a very nice
um yeah initiated a very nice counter
play now he played knight c6
of course just attacking the queen
it dropped back to e3
of course white could also play queen d2
but queen e3 was played
knight g4 attacking the queen
queen d2 and now
in this position um
he played um
a very very nice move
he played b5 which looks uh at first
rather surprising because white is
over protecting the square really with
lots of pieces pawn knight bishop but uh
it seems to work
he now took
and retakes okay let's start with the
easiest moves this bishop is hanging
um yeah well
even even even here so bishop b5 is not
working
just takes it
and this means you need to check knight
takes b5 but this is answered by queen
b6
and this is quite nice attacking f2
and we have white needs to attend to
this and what would you play you cannot
move this knight
like knight d4 as a3 is hanging
and if you uh would move the bishop
let's say like this then there's bishop
a6 and you've got them a huge problem
because there's a very funny line 1994
takes
takes
and here
black has
a really really funny move
rook takes a2 if white would now
recapture
then there's d5
of course this is a very is a bit
computer-ish but just to
look at what is possible
knight moves and knight takes f2
and
this is winning for black now
as queen takes bishop c5 loses the queen
and the threats after bishop f2 are just
after knight takes f2 are just too much
instead of the the rook taking on a3
which is really very computer-ish
there's also bishop h4 which is strong
attacking this pawn and if you protect
it with g3 then bishop g5 is very
annoying attacking the queen
and if queen moves now let's say here
then taking on f2 this is actually
possible for a human to see
rook takes a3 is um a bit um
a bit too much maybe
all right so this is a
fun way to uh justify the b5 move
nakamura went back to b2 not much choice
but this means b4 is possible
and white
only has
really this square on the edge of the
board knight b5 would have been
bad leading to the same
kinds of
bad coordination but now you've got this
knight on the rim
and certainly black has comfortable
position
bishop d7 taking a look at this knight
knight d4
knight c5 are very logical blacks
advantage lies in the extra center pawn
and this offside
piece and now i might grab this point so
interesting play queen
b4 rook b8
and
in fact you
immediately suspect that there's some
tactic going here because it looks
so uncoordinated queen c3 this was the
idea
and queen b7
here
nakamura grabbed on g4
knight takes
and now he played the very normal
looking move queen g3
the queen is um
really a
weird position on c3 queen g3 looks very
uh
very logical white had a really weird
tactical alternative here i just want to
show it briefly this is knight c6
attacking his g7 with mate
but black can reply bishop f6 and funny
enough white has
the reply
e5 in this position
which is probably not sufficient but
it's just funny that this is
possible at all
if you look at this queen takes e5 i can
even take on b8
and maybe i'm even better as white
winning an exchange
there's no big discovery here with the
knight
and um
yeah b8 is hanging and this bishop is
saying so
probably black needs to play something
like this
and this um
leads to uh leads to equality probably
queen g3 now or queen takes c6 it's
maybe also sufficient for
okay yeah it's probably equal look d6
black can get to get on a four pawn back
probably equal
so queen uh knight c6 was a fun move but
queen g3 is normal
black um regained the pawn
and of course
f3 qd3 is
suicidal
so 93 and queen back to g6
yeah and this position now
is much more comfortable for black it
already was before but
now it has
sort of
um
yeah transformed into another type of
advantage before black's um good
position was due to
the bad knight on a4
and now he's got
these two central pawns and two bishops
and this is not looking good for white
a4
g5
e5 was also interesting but d5 was good
avoiding the trade
yeah i've got queens off white couldn't
really
um prevent this and now the pawns start
to roll in the
center queen
knight back and here black um i think
had had a better move
he played
d4 which also um
looks like um it preserves some some
nice advantage but probably stronger was
even bishop f5
attacking this rook first and if white
would move the rook now
let's say here
then d4
there's not knight e4 possible and this
knight e4 is a bit um helping white
with coordinating the pieces
here he probably needs to
go um go to um
d5 d5
and this is a problem bishop e6 coming
so this seems to be
better it's still complicated you can
continue this line with bishop d6
and so on
it's not easy but well g4 also kept an
advantage
he um actually made a mistake later
we can
go on a couple of moves which is
oh this is easy to understand white
tries to activate his knights
but black has this static advantage no
these two pawns
and the two bishops
and he did everything right advancing
the pawns
pushing them forward slowly
but in fact a couple of moves later he
played um he made a mistake
97 initiating some exchanges
so at least the bishop has gone now
but black still has this
big center here
and white has got um
b3 as a weakness somewhat passive knight
still um a very good position for
for black
yeah like i'm where i now played knight
c4 with very little time on the clock
left
just one minute one minute
and here black
could have improved he played rook to g6
looks uh good attacking g2 but
there was a better move probably just
taking on b3 was was stronger
but nige's
rook g6 was of course a tempting move
the idea of this is if knight oops
knight takes e5 now
which is uh the move white certainly
would have played
then rook e6
knight takes d7 rook e7 and
the problem is that this knight is
somewhat stranded it doesn't have a good
square
let's say knight here rook c3
knight a6 or b6 so it's a
sort of
golden moment that uh black could uh
could take use of here because this
knight
is so uh so badly placed it now would
need to go here
rook b6 and uh
now we're at the point where this knight
really doesn't have a square
where would you go i mean you can go to
a2 but this is not really a square
but probably it's necessary and then
black can play something like this and
has a really huge advantage
this is falling it's um
a dangerous pawn a good night so
the computer um assassins this is
completely winning actually
this was a big chance for giri just
taking here
book g6 looks good but doesn't seem to
be a sufficient white took now on e5
rook takes on g2
king f1
and now we played the rook h2 but the
problem is
after this king move
that's not really something else this
knight is hanging and if you
think about that rook d4 israeli threat
but the knight is hanging and this is a
problem really
um in fact the game after rook g2 king
f1 and rook h2
was was drawn now check repeating and um
black really cannot do much else this
this is simply hanging
and if you would move it yeah let's say
you would move the bishop bishop e6
and white has also
this annoying move
attacking the knight and this knight is
protecting this rook on g2
yeah it's simply not a position where
you can play for witness black
you need to take the draw
so an interesting game that giri i think
played a really good game i mean b5 was
a very cool
move this one
and
he sort of i think outplayed
nakamura here but he didn't manage to
really win it at the end
so um this
rook a6 uh to g6 instead of rook takes
b3
was miss chance
yeah
so let me check quickly do i really have
all games covered no i don't want to
forget one again yeah i've got it all
and it took me
18 minutes this is a record
yeah i hope you are still awake after
this 18 minutes of chess
thanks for watching and i'll be back
tomorrow
with
round 10.